God have you guys seen that you know
what one of my faith
dude you know what actually I want to do
first of all you got to look up this one
video this is my favorite video I never
laughed so hard at a blooper then this
one here this tech TV blooper right here
okay dude I never left a one-of-a dude I
never left I never left harder at a
blooper video than this one oh my god
dude okay this is older man I've shown
you this right this older man
it's called tech TV blooper his older
man and this guy is well here I'll just
play it this is a one-of-a-kind piece
there's no other one like this
particular one in the world and you can
see the tracks go this way and it's
really cool because it records much more
accurately oh my god oh my god okay he's
literally just holding it nothing's
happening and it just explodes he didn't
drop it and then it is a one-of-a-kind
like this particular one in the world
and you can see the tracks go this way
and it's really cool because it records
much more accurately oh my god he goes
oh he was gonna say [ __ ] but then didn't
because you want to swear at me he says
[ __ ] like this second wave of uh-oh
just overwhelmed when he was like I
guess I got to say [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god this he says oh my god - which is
it's really cool because it records much
more accurately but oh oh my god
well that does happen every once in a
while that can't be good
now are you doing yeah I'm done with
that that's so funny are you done with
that one it just exploded huh
yeah you're done with it that one and
then the [ __ ] ladder the QVC ladder
one forget it do it forget it dude I
don't know which one I like better I
don't know which one I like better dude
this one oh my god the home-shopping
ladder blooper this one right here first
of all this is the dumbest the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen in my life
it's a ladder that [ __ ] will put it
on the video podcast but it goes up and
you can make it go across and then down
for at and the reason for no [ __ ]
reason alright so he's showing how to do
it and he's crawling across the ladder
it's a very easy that equation to
operate you just push the buttons in
right here on the two sides the two
little buttons and all you do is push
them in and that will release it and
went right here push the button and that
releases it and then after you let go it
locks perfectly in place so really
you're also and this is tough and this
is tough
alright any by the way guys who as or as
tall as the woman they're talking to are
the are the most hilarious guys like it
doesn't matter how tall you are if you
are as tall as the woman you're talking
to you are a savage now the woman can be
6 - I'm 6 - if the woman's 6 - and I'm
talking to 6 - a woman I am therefore
submit now that happens way less because
I'm 62 and not many women are 62 but if
you're as tall as the woman you're
talking to you are a submit and you're
drawing the [ __ ] up and that's just how
it is now her [ __ ] is going like this
because it's dry congratulations but
that's how it is okay now this guy is
trying to show this girl how the ladder
works because he's a representative of
the ladder and it is her job to be on
the show and have this guy on and tried
sell his letters now she is wearing for
some reason a goddamn gown now that's
[ __ ] stupid because she looks
ridiculous
couldn't look more Mormon and he is as
tall as her therefore he is asked a
[ __ ] now he locks it up they go back a
little bit
look I couldn't look more like he sings
in that [ __ ] what is that were they
the Four Seasons should be is it the
Four Seasons no it's one fire one fire
it's all good but one fire Frankie Valli
and the [ __ ] degenerate or some [ __ ]
you know the generous is probably would
that that does definitely a group the
Four Seasons okay Frankie Valli example
so he now he tried to crawl across it
right she has no [ __ ] idea dude she
has absolutely zero idea right right and
he's crawling across dude you don't
understand this ladder how do I describe
it for the audio listeners so the ladder
it it's it's a bridge you crawl up it
and then you crawl across it and then I
guess down and he's like say you have to
go but you could just use a regular
ladder for the [ __ ] you have to get up
on the wall I said oh you mean what a
regular ladder does okay I write the
best I never realize how awesome and
loaded her right is do the casualness of
höwedes listen just walk right up okay
so he's know he's walking up Wow so
[ __ ] how he looks when he's walking
right up okay okay now what happened
right there was he buckled a little bit
like about I'd say 10 inches and he
almost fell and he's crawling across it
which means if it did buckle his face
would go directly into the ground okay
so Frankie Valli
the guy goddamn frankie valli [ __ ]
chick he's talking to oh my god all
right so all right so so now atlanna
neat and then he's so [ __ ] goddamn
scared but he says it's in aus locked in
place so there goes cuz he has to cuz he
has to because he's trying to sell these
he has no choice but to now that's the
that's the best dude there's nothing
funnier than that the guy has to sell
these ladders because he's a
representative ladder I don't know if he
owns a letter or what but he's
represented he needs to make money dude
so he goes to crawl across it he said
now it's completely safe it's locked in
place and then it falls a little bit
scaring everyone and then he says say
now it's locked in place he has no
choice otherwise he will sell 0 the only
hope that he has to sell any is to crawl
across and and nothing bad have happened
nothing that happens but as you can see
it does not say his chin goes directly
into the ground and he's actually I
didn't have it locked yeah no [ __ ] also
don't need it get a regular ladder dude
if you need to go to this and then it
cuts immediately to the stock footage of
the ladder which is the best the guy was
on standby it cuts so quickly the guy
was not he's like he hit into me because
he knew frankie valli was gonna hit it
dude when he said actually I didn't have
it locked
[Music]
you have to lock it once you lock it
you're okay but
it is very safe to operate through the
steam coming out of like the wind out of
it at the end that last layer just so
defeated so defeated it is very safe to
operate new just people hanging up
across the country you have to love it
once you lock it you okay but you got a
look at this video look at the different
the different [ __ ] things you can do
with the ladder is just so hilarious
look at this one dude why would you do
that why would you do that
they made it 1-1 where you can just it
go it's like up down like a zigzag
across the ground what the [ __ ] would
you want to do that with a ladder
what would you do that except hurt
yourself and it's $200 $200 for chipped
teeth Wow 3.3 million when I first saw
that video I was had no hits do it wow
we were laughing hard me my brother I
mean look at the things that come up QVC
ladder fall death QVC knife how about
the [ __ ] 100 got me that one
the samurai one you know that one you
busy the the the fact the way they have
to save face is so funny dude cuz they
can't be like oh you know they got to be
like get me here we go why are these
guys screaming always 11:01 get your mic
1101 1816 is the item number on this one
and the nice thing about these practice
guitar
oh that hurt Oh the blade comes off and
stabs his abdomen that hurt big-time
a piece of that just the tip just got me
O'Dell you stabbed yourself
I love all these guys always try to
minimize it dude you why can't you just
be hurt like Elliot got
Oh a piece of that just got me stabbed
himself a piece of that just got me yet
Odell - you are a piece of that tip just
got me it's the guy emergency surgery
the guy I mean he's like Ethan hit his
eye
dude when when the guy when Odell
somebody who commented working at by one
of those tables Odell afterwards oh we
might need to get like just a craft
service guy we may need to get emergency
surgery like he's just a [ __ ] what's
his name uh Mike judge character [ __ ] is
so funny good but but let's look up the
[ __ ] one that I've been meaning to
look this one up its first so long Jim
Rome Jim Everett one this is so this is
where the coin we coined I think my
brother and I coin probably submit is
such a big term and me my brother's life
and it had been brewing and bubbling but
thus abit
[ __ ] came like this is what one of the
first seeds of my brother and I starting
to call everything so [ __ ]
Jim Rome that's not what everyone Jim
Rome Jim Rome here we go versus Chris
Evert first of all so such bad footage
like dude how come in the night [ __ ] do
you ever see old footage of [ __ ] you're
like how did I ever watch TV it looks at
you're watching without the [ __ ]
glasses on it's so bad
HD is everything like how did you use to
jerk off the porn on VHS the [ __ ] looks
like a [ __ ] what do you call it a
like the product like the [ __ ] techno
ball or some [ __ ] tech mobile techno
tech mobile tech mobile yeah so so Jim
Rome is interviewing Jim Everett and he
calls him keeps his good Chris Evert was
a female tennis player and Jim Rome
would say on his program that Jim
Everett he would call Chris Evert
because he thought he played like a
[ __ ] I guess weaker than he normally
does weaker than a football that I
should play like if he was doing the
sexist like yeah you play like a girl
thing so Jim Everett now finally gets on
his show and calls him out and it's so
fun he's now playing for that team I
mean Jim Rome it's the short Frankie
Valli type guys that are the most submit
guys in the world just how he says check
that Chris Everett like just so heated
so first of all so shitty to invite a
guy on your show just to be shitty to
him so bad journalism like be a little
bit more cagey and then he was coming he
knew it was coming Jim Everett knew was
coming so hard look
you know what anything I guess it's you
know what they knew it was coming oh
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] two years actually
Chris and then again twist the knife oh
it got me right there twisted it
I called him Chris again how nervous and
nervous
both these guys so nervous Jim Rome so
nervous because Jim Eric could beat the
[ __ ] out of him and Jim ever so nervous
because he's in an interview and doesn't
want to be exposed
they have nervous smile so hard their
biggest but so long the way Jim ceased
being Jimmy became Chris and secure let
me tell you a little secret that we're
sitting here right now not secret that's
the best one cuz because Jim Rome is
trying to let go back and be like well
already did twice I don't have to do
this call you out on your threat thing
so that should count and you should be
beating me up already but you're not
going to and I'm calling you out on that
[ __ ] but Jim Everett everyone five
minute segment got so nervous or five
segment show five minute segment or five
seconds so every both of them are so
nervous right now it's so funny
dude what we do well we do and he's
smiling
did I just before we even play it the
beat Jim Rome takes before he decides to
call him Chris again is the most unreal
beat ever taken Chris
the sound goes tosses the table up and
just tosses him down the way Jim Rome
gets up to his savage this little [ __ ]
dude that's the kind of [ __ ] you get
knocked the [ __ ] out if you do that
Chris Jim Rome is a [ __ ] for that
though I'm sorry Jim ever it's a [ __ ]
for that go to rest
oh this that's fake
that parts fake oh wait is that really
what that is no because they turn the
mic off I'll tell you what dude if
somebody [ __ ] called me out on that
[ __ ] oh I'd love to call them JIT I'd
love to call him Chris again come on
Chris let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dude
he got fair warning to me a did this is
a doctor this is doctor why did they do
that should not really know that's the
best you call me Chris Evert to my face
will murder me I already did it twice
ah man that's so funny the whole thing
is so [ __ ]